ne vous laissez donc pas impressionner
par les manœuvres de ceux qui veulent
refermer les portes des bureaux de vote
nous nous allons les maintenir largement
ouvert tout le monde se réveille en
fonction des derniers sondages pour
savoir ce qui avantage qui moi je dire
juste une chose il s'agit pas que ça
serve de prétexte pour contester le
résultat
final j'espère que ce sera pas ça parce
qu'ors là ce serait pire que tout je ne
cherche pas la bénédiction du Petit
Paris mondain je cherche la résurrection
du peuple de France voilà la différence
entre eux et nous mais du coup les gens
un peu mou qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
franchement je respecte d'abord dans la
situation dans laquelle je suis faut que
je sois bien avec tout le monde mais
hnêement ça me parle pas la manière dont
l'élection se profile c'est on vote pas
pour quelque chose on vote contre
quelqu'un on parle des
femmes j'ai un bilan énorme oui entre
autres
[Rires]
c'est vrai vous êtes mis en examen je
cite pour Rossel de favoritisme et
détournement de fond public on reviendra
dans un instant c'est bien pour vous
ariez pu ajouter que je suis descend en
ligne direct de Gilles deay et de
Jacquel ventreur elle vous aime pour
vous profondément pour l' pleer non mais
c'est vrai
Mo je suis désolée bon c'est une
histoire ordinaire il y a 60000 parents
en France qui ont des enfants prématurés
et c'est toujours difficile s'il n'y
avait pas de discussion sur cette
candidature tout le monde soutiendrait
euh François Hollande avec des réusite
avec un enthousiasme avec de l'espoir il
a rien de tout ça si vous avez Alzheimer
vous savez quoi je vais venir avec vous
vous faites Karine au fait qu'est-ce que
j'aime bien
manger
hein acclamé par ses supporter hier soir
à New York Donald Trump effectue sa
première sortie depuis le scandale de
ses propos sexistes révélé dans une
vidéo je suis automatiquement attiré par
les belles femmes je les embrasse tout
de suite c'est comme un aimant je les
embrasse je n'attends pas quand on est
une star elle nous laisse faire on fait
tout ce qu'on
veut j'ai dit et j'ai fait des choses
que je regrette les mots publiés
aujourd'hui datent de plus de 10 ans et
ça en fait partie
en arrivant il ne se sont même pas serré
la main et dès la deè question du débat
la polémique du weekend entre en jeu
nous l'avons vu violer les femmes en se
basant sur leur apparence en les
classant de 1 et 10 quand je vois Trump
parler je me dis que le
populisme c'est pas défense du peuple
contrairement à ce que récl toujours
tous les populistes c'est le mépris du
peuple je suis pas fier ce que j'ai
maiséit quelque chose qui s passé si
vous regardez B Clinton il s'est
comporté beaucoup plus mal moi quelques
minutes avant ce deè débat le
milliardaire a donné une conférence de
presse autour de lui plusieurs femmes
qui affirment avoir été violé par
l'ancien président des
États-Unis
j'entends de tel propos ça me rappelle
le conseil de mon ami Michel Obama quand
il frappe en dessous de la ceinture il
faut frapper
audessus je nai jamais
vtique je tradandme j'espère bien que
jamais une campagne française ne tombera
à ce niveau d'ignom la question vous
n'aimez pas qu'on vous
Monsieur le Maire vous êtes Le Maire dou
quel est le petit surnom que vous donne
votre épouse Coquito combien de
personneroupement
familial le regroupement familial c'est
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes par an c'est 12000 plusieurs
centaines de milliers pourelou Trump
c'est le Morano en santiag ça vous fait
sourire AG je trouve ça estce que vous
êtes plongé dans ce dossier vous en
parlez sans savoir sans connaître que
nous reprochons au responsables
politiques qu'v pas l'avance du maire de
Bordeaux est de 14 points sur son
concurrent Nicolas Sarkozi 42%
d'intention de vote contre 28 % pour
l'ancien président au second tour les
chiffres montent même jusqu'à 62 % pour
Alain Jupé non seulement j'y crois
encore mais je m'interroge si vous
voulez sur la la qualité des des
sondages je dis pas que les sondages se
trompent tout le temps je pense que pour
la primaire choses sont compliqué les
policiers sont invités par leur syndicat
à se rassembler devant les commissariats
ou plus traité que les urgences façon
pour eux de manifester leur ralbol après
la tentative de meurtre de vierry
Châtillon ils ont été confrontés à une
bande de sauvageon qui ont agi avec
l'âcheté un sauvageon c'est gentillet là
ce sont des hommes qui ont voulu tuer le
Premier ministre a raison de dire qu'il
ne faut pas qu'il y ait de zones de non
droit mais il y mais à mon avis il y en
a beaucoup à reconquérir la délinquence
d'aujourd'hui et ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui qui est une américanisation
de la violence moi d'abord je pense à ce
policier entre la vie et la mort mais
tout le monde répondz pas ma
question moi je répond pas aux questions
je vais bien vous répondre aux questions
ou elle va bien répondre aux questions
Rachida la preuve quelques secondes plus
tard
lorsqueudreara la lance sur é zour le
pauvre je le plains je plains surtout sa
famille ses enfants mais je le plains
mais voilà c'est tout moi j'en fais pas
une obsession il en fait une obsession
mais moi je trouve que vous l'invitiez
etre liberté de recevoir les invités
qu'on veut vous rentrez de Moscou
Alexandre est-ce que vladimire veut
toujours lui venir à Paris bah bien sûr
qu'il veut venir à Paris 2h plus tard
Vladimir Poutine a annulé ce matin sa
visite prévue à Paris le 19 octobre
François Hollande hésitait sérieusement
à le recevoir à cause du profond
desésaccord sur la Syrie le dialogue est
nécessaire avec la Turquie mais avec la
Russie mais il doit être ferme et franc
sinon il na pas sa place le porte-parole
de la présidence russe a fait savoir
Vladimir Poutine reste se disposer à
visiter Paris lorsque le président
Hollande se sentira à l'aise pour le
voir je suis donc prêt à tout moment à
rencontrer le président Poutine mais si
nous avons la
possibilité de faire avancer la cause de
la paix l'annulation de la visite est
une très mauvaise chose cette stratégie
qui consiste à faire la guerre froide
avec la Russie est une erreur c'est
invraisemblable d'avoir un président de
la République qui soit encore une fois
qui est versé dans cette diplomatie
d'opérette ce qui nous a
particulièrement intéressé Yan lors de
cette petite visite sur le port c'est le
déjeuner d'Alain Jupé allit casser la
croûte il est il a cassé la croûte avec
le sénateur Jean-Jacques Panunzi
actuellement poursuivi pour favoritisme
détournement de fonds public et recours
au travail dissimulé je me suis exprimé
et je crois que les Français ont compris
et qui m'ont relégitimé à plusieurs
reprises je voudrais rajouter une seule
chose je vis on parle beaucoup de l'État
de droit tous ces personnages que vous
citez donc l'état de droit à la bouche
qu'est-ce que c'est que at de droit
c'est la non rétroactivité de la loi
pénale il y avait le maire d'Ajaccio
Laurent marcangelli qui a déjà connu une
élection invalidé pour manœuvre
frauduleuse alors c'est sûr que pour
s'afficher devant les journalistes il y
a mieux comme table vous savez en
matière judiciaire il veut mieux avoir
un passé qu'unenir estce que vous aurez
pas pu composer une table plus
irréprochable ce n'est pas moi qui fait
la liste des invités et de toute façon
moi je respecte la présomption
d'innocence alors si vous faites la
chasse transformez-vous en juge il est
bavard François Hollande et n'a pas la
langue dans sa poche un long ont
entretient en nouvelles et 660 pages de
confession dans un livre un président ne
devrait pas dire ça malheureusement les
journalistes qui l'ont écrit en raison
un président de la République ne devrait
pas s'exprimer comme ça ne devrait pas
faire ses confidences sur le port du
voile la femme voilée d'aujourd'hui sera
la Marianne de demain avec ces mots le
locataire de l'Élysée estime que le
voile peut être une protection pour une
citoyenne mais que demain elle s'en
libérera il y a un problème avec l'islam
et d'ajouter que ce n'est pas la
religion qui est dangereuse en elle-même
mais que le problème c'est que l'islam
veut s'affirmer comme une religion dans
la République je suis très surpris de
voir François Hollande le dire parce
qu'il a longtemps nié après avoir lancé
une campagne d'affichage antimigrant
avec le slogan ça y est ils arrivent
Robert Menard a annoncé la tenue d'un
référendum en janvier prochain en cause
l'agrandissement d'un des deux centres
pour réfugiés de la ville le Président
n'en reste pas là y compris sur les
ténors de son camp Jean-M quand il était
Premier ministre tellement loyal qu'il
est inaudible Najat Val Belkassem elle
est bonne Najat très forte en langue de
bois les vers des cyniqu et des
emmerdeurs Nicolas Sarkozi qualifié de
grossier et méchant en prend aussi pour
son grade c'est le petit de Gaulle c'est
un lapin du racel toujours en train de
s'agiter non mais il se prend pour
Victor Hugo il a des confidences qui
sont très sérieux mais très franchement
un président de la République n'a pas à
faire ses confidences on lui demande pas
ça on s'en fout de ses confidences il y
a une chose qui m'étonne c'est qu' il
est le temps de passer des centaines
d'heures avec des équipes de
journalistes diverses et variés c'est le
deuxème livre de ce genreel il y a un
mois il y en avait un autre aussi avec
deux journalistes qui révélaient l'avoir
vu plusieurs dizaines de fois il passe
son temps à voir des journalistes mais
autre faç faire passer est-ce qu'il
n'avait pas d'autres choses à faire
est-ce qu'il n'avait pas s'occuper des
affaires de la France Alex compagne de
François Hollande et qui publie donc via
Twitter un sms qu'elle attribue à
François Hollande daté de de 2005 ouais
d'accord bon avec ça je laisse les
Français faire leur jugement dans son
Descours à la fait un lapsus formidable
r général même chez les sendans si vous
dépassez la minute et bien voilà cette
lumière rouge très visible aux yeux de
tous s'allumera pas trop difficile une
minute de temps de parole chacun si ça
va être très dur vous n'avez pas
vraiment répondu à la question qui vous
était posée la prochaine fois madame je
vous répondrai la prochaine fois vous
prendrez votre minute pour le faire à
tout à l'heure jean- Frédéric poisson
euh Françis quelque chose à dire avant
alors je on a un petit peu travaillé les
questions et les réponses et après
déjeuner après je crois reposer et faire
un on très probablement ça compte dans
le repos pour lui vous savez j va dire
que je suis malhonnête moi je vais dire
qu'il est vieux bref on sera pas en
primaire mais en maternelle Vous
sentezvous vous-même visé par Bruno Le
Maire ou par ce que disait il y a peu
François Fillon qui disait sans doute
parlant de vous qui imagine de Gaulle
mise en
examen
ce ne sont pas des déclarations qui
honorent ceux qui les prononce que
Nicolas Sarkozi se retrouve au milieu ça
c'est super et à 80 cm de son pire
ennemi qui est Jean-François Copé le
hasard fait quand même très bien les
choses hein vous estimez que votre
voisin Nicolas Sarkozi n'a pas sa place
dans cette prère non non pas du tout je
que les choses soient très claires c'est
c'est à chacun d'en décider pour ce qui
me concerne je considère qu'à partir du
moment où j'aurais été mis en examen
cela signifiait que j'étais susceptible
d'être envoyé devant un tribunal ce qui
me paraissait incompatible pour ce qui
me concerne ça va être un beau moment
démocratique un beau moment pourer sa
vision de la France ses idées les
valeurs que nous défendons si vous
voulez que tout continue comme avant et
bien vous avez tout ce qu'il faut sur ce
plateau mais si vous voulez que cela
change vraiment alors choisissez le
renouveau je regarde la primaire qui est
en train de commencer et quand je vois
ce que disait quelquefois le président
précédent et ce qu'il dit aujour'
aujourd'hui en terme de crédibilité
monsieur le Président je vous renvoie au
débat de ce soir je ne seraiis pas le
Martine au BRI de droite c'est-à-dire
qu'on a eu une obsédée des 35h on va pas
être une ob des obsédé des 39h je veux
pas supprimer des fonctionnaires je vous
rassure vous voulez qu'à la fin il y en
a moins phiement non je sais bien je
suis quelqu'un de Pacifique bien il
s'agit de supprimer des emplois publics
quand je l'ai dit il y a 18 mois on m'a
rayonné et certains et par exemple
certains parmi tes soutiens Nicolas ont
dit bah c'est irresponsable et
aujourd'hui je vois que tout le monde
reprend l'idée tant mieux les bonnes
idées sont faites pour être il y a des
déçus du hollandisme qui parfois avent
voté pour Nicolas Sarkozi précédemment
et bien si aujourd'hui ils veulent venir
vers nous ils sont les bienvenus je vais
y aller je vais boire un café je je
souhaite pas que vous perdiez votre
audience en route avec vous on est sûr
de faire très haut non mais c'est pas il
y a pas d'ironie de ma part ça va
remonter ça va
remonter